how's it goin rez my speed back Bobby's
back I misty Bob I don't even remember
how you play this H mana skate hates me
now that's not quite how you do it whoa
skate three doing all the coolest tricks
Bob your shoe is not your penis I keep
telling you all right we better get out
of here if people don't seem too
friendly I could use a hug oh my god I
love benches can I sit with you
goddamn it every time oh no I'm stuck
Wow ah the benches in this game are so
flawless look at this I think you're
better than me bet you know what I am a
better bench you can sit on me on that
long girl come here
ma come on I said sit on it oh that's
how we do it
temp I don't run away from me senpai I
love you
senpai maybe that guy go samp is always
it oh my god a bench
I love benches Star Wars Episode two
senpai Strikes Back senpai I brought
this present I brought this for you
y'all run I love you target acquired
bench attack got ya oh my god is robbed
I wreck
I love you Bob Derrick dance for me Rob
really dance that's right
dancing keep dancing Ron you're a
natural-born dancer
knock cut it out Oh target acquired
yeah hey girls
um what is she doing with that thing ha
ha ha ha ha what is she doing
can I sit with you ah every time why why
does no one want to sit with me I will
pay god damn I missed ah missed this
time there's no escape
boom [ __ ] oh my god on some bench
lovers love me please thank you oh oh oh
oh oh hey why do you fight it
hahahahahahaha
the power of bobs crotches is amazing
look at that bench where'd he go
oh that's not how your time trees Bob
that's not how it's done
oh I told you all right one more try
great great job this will be the
greatest Bob of all time here we go here
it comes
we're good a little slow actually there
we go
nope yo what Bob what'd I tell you
you're not a vibrator no you're not
come on now you're just being racist
what did you say to me I'll show you
gotcha [ __ ] hahaha and skating is the
best just love skateboarding have you
guys seen my hat
you guys like my hat there's anyone like
my hat any one place it's me hey no need
to fight where hey beautiful nice water
best water I have seen in my life have
you guys seen this water it's so good I
want to swim in it got a bow
oh ah how for the love of God this game
I didn't ask for this ah someone do
something I gave it I am big look at it
oh my god
where oh hey Lanie what are you looking
at yeah [ __ ] you lady oh god it happened
oh god what am I going
Wow
my people are calling me Wow oh I'm
scared buddy finally I love it Oh
[ __ ] risque fun
yeah that's right ah yeah go let's go
somewhere private
then one see that I was amazing I'm
preggers with skatey
hey man hope you're having a great day
oh gosh best glitch ever how ahh oh god
what happened
Oh God Bom ahh what you actually thought
we were gonna skate in this episode
don't be ridiculous
alright press gotta have the end of that
episode here thank you for leaving it
like and commenting on this video and I
will see you bros in the new epic and
get what the [ __ ] are you doing
and dog shot bro fist